welcome everyone
thank you for joining us today and
welcome to the first
session of the clinical oncology track
of our thermo fisher
apj genetic solutions tour 2020
my name is bansi sangvi and i will be
your moderator for this session
in this session we will hear about our
latest next generation sequencer the
iron torrent genexis system
and its application in clinical oncology
research
first we will hear from dr john sherlock
director
global product management oncology
clinical sequencing division from
thermal fissure scientific
john is based in california where he
runs the oncology product management
group
in the clinical sequencing division
developing and managing
diagnostic and research products
including
our first ivd-labelled ngs kit
for solid tumor testing as well as
assays for immunology
cell reapplication heme oncology
and pediatric cancer testing for a
complete biography on dr sherlock
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
today he will talk to us about how the
iron throne genexis
system will simplify your molecular
profiling journey
by addressing key challenges in next
generation sequencing
implementation like hands-on time time
to result
user expertise and affordability
we encourage you to submit your
questions in the q a box
and john will address them at the end of
his presentation
please join me in welcoming john
sherlock
thank you very much for that kind
introduction i'm going to talk
about how to simplify your journey of
molecular profiling with
single day next generation sequencing
as i'm sure you're aware next generation
sequencing has the promise
to revolutionize precision oncology
clinical research
with the abundance of information that
we have available to us
and the increasing amount of exploration
and research that's revealing
additional genes the dna level at the
fusion level
tumor mutation burden sequential testing
for one marker after another is pretty
much impossible in this day and age
so next generation sequencing bringing
the ability
to bring all this information to bear in
one single test
is extremely compelling
however next generation sequencing or
ngs
isn't available um and utilizable
immediately for everybody today
systems can be too slow requiring days
often weeks to get a result
the process can be extremely complex
often requiring different machines
multiple touch points and a high level
of
expertise to actually run the mgs system
also it can be very costly to train
staff to hire
staff and having to to batch
samples together to reach a sensible
critical mass
can be can be difficult and costly
and also the utility of ngs has been
restrained
by most platforms requiring quite a
large amount of material
quite a large amount of tissue to
actually get a result which can be
extremely limiting
i'd like to present to you today a real
new dawn
in precision oncology with the release
of the
the iron torrent genexis integrated
sequencer
the iron torrent genexis system is the
the latest
generation of ngs platforms from thermo
fisher scientific
as we go through the rest of the
presentation i'll show you how it's
extremely fast
and within a single day you can go from
sample to report
how it's essentially hands-free there
are two touch points
and only 10 minutes of hands-on time in
the entire process
also how it can be cost saving with the
flexibility of running a very small
number of samples even a single
sample in a split lane system on the
chip
through to running the complete chip
there's a high flexibility
and also the success with tissue saving
how as little as 10 nanograms of input
nucleic acid
will give reliable results almost every
single time
so now with the with the new iron
torrent genexis system
you're able to get results from sample
to answer of
ngs around the same time as
immunohistochemistry
this is really quite revolutionary with
the limited amount of hands-on time it's
very scalable it's fully automated
very easy to train anybody to operate
the system
as i've said the the chips are split
into lanes
so this reduces the need for batching
and you can deliver results however many
samples you have to process
faster than ever before although the
system is currently sold
for research units only we have built it
under a registered
facility with the fda and it's iso 13485
certified
which gives us a lot of possibilities
for future development
so let's talk about some of the assays
that we have available now and those
that are coming
on the genexis platform we have
developed it
for consideration for both ffpe blocks
for blood for other tissues and also
cell free plasma material
we launched the platform at the very end
of 2019
and at that point supporting any custom
ion
and sig hd panel um that's the antique
hd is our latest chemistry
and also the older ampliseq chemistry as
well for any custom platform
also we have the iron ampliseq demand
panels
as we moved into the beginning of this
year
we have launched a new oncoming assay
called the oncoming precision assay or
opa
we'll talk more about that in the coming
slides it's a 50
g marker for use on both ffpe and liquid
biopsy samples
we've also released the oncoming
comprehensive version 3
assay on genexis this is a 153 larger
gene panel of dna
and rna fusion detection and also
the the tcr beta long read assay t cell
receptors
for translational research in immune
oncology
as we move into the second half of this
year we will soon launch
the oncoming myeloid assay and the
oncoming bracker assay onto the genexis
with many more many more assays to come
in 2021 and beyond
so a little more about the oncoming
precision assay
it is a pan cancer content of 50
key genes covering all the the
clinically relevant mutations the copy
number variants
many different fusion variants as well
tumor suppressor drivers
and resistant variants the assay is
designed with a single
workflow in to
use either ffpe tissue
or plasma samples so with the same lab
workflow
you can analyze cell-free material or a
tumor biopsy
the approach is to use our ampliseq hd
chemistry
in this assay which has molecular
tagging this allows the extremely
high sensitivity of detecting very very
low levels of variance which
allows the ate to be used for the liquid
biopsy application
we've also developed new rna fusion
detection technology
we've termed fusion sync more about this
in later slides
so the one assay kit can be used for
different applications
if you're interested only in a dna
mutation spectrum for ffpe
you could run 32 samples across the
whole chip likewise if you
were only interested in the rna fusion
content you could run 32
rna samples on the one chip if you're
interested as most people we believe
will be in looking at both the dna
and the rna you can run up to 16 samples
across the uh the genexis chip that's
four samples on each of the lanes
or just four samples on one lane it has
that flexibility or even one sample
if you're interested in cell free total
nucleic acid
you can run up to four liquid biopsy
samples
on the genetics platform in one go
the fusion think technology
we believe uh brings the most uh
valuable approach
to detecting fusion drivers
in oncology samples there are two key
parameters to consider
when you're selecting the technology to
use one is the performance of
of the fusion detection with very low
input
of material together with heterogeneity
and also
low level of transcripts within the
sample so it needs to be very sensitive
the second is also how comprehensive the
approach is how many
different fusions and different futures
from the same driver
can be detected many approaches
emphasize
number two here rather than considering
both one and two with fusion sync we
address
both of these very important parameters
so what is fusion sync it's a
combination of three different
approaches
one is targeting known fusions this is
where we have the driver gene
and we have the partner gene and we
troll through the literature
and have many many hundreds in a
regularly
updated and curated database we design
specifically across
this fusion breakpoint and so there
we would detect the known driver gene
the known partner
and at the known breakpoint within the
design also
we have designs where we don't
necessarily need the exact break point
but we do know the driver gene and we
know the partner gene still
we would just have them spanning a
larger region and pick up
fusions with a previously unknown break
point
both these methods are incredibly
sensitive and
robust and enable you of course to
identify the exact future transcript
that you're detecting
that you're sequencing all the way
across
we also have this new approach of exon
tiling
imbalance this is where we design
amplicons across the length
of the messenger rna transcript and by
looking at relative read amounts
we can detect an imbalance so here we
know
only the driver gene we don't need any
additional knowledge and we'll pick up
a fusion event
so the benefits of of the targeted
approach as i've said is that expenses
of
sensitivity and here's a couple of
studies that we highlight which show
how our approach can pick up really low
levels of expression
the three different colors here and this
is from a poster from a doctor's song
from
cornell at the reefson amp conference
this looks at the dilution series of
of a known control with the fusion mix
contained within it and as you go
through the dilution series
different technologies drop off at
different at different times
here we're represented with the yellow
with the only approach
which actually picked up this fusion
every single
dilution into different fusions
um going down the titration series
other approaches don't have that level
of sensitivity which is really important
clearly if you if you have a low
expressed fusion driver
maybe a poor quality sample a small
amount you
need to be confident of picking it up
the exon tiling imbalance approach
allows us as i've said to detect these
novel fusions
so by measuring the expressive ratio
across the gene you if you have a normal
expression you'd expect a balanced line
and this is what's represented here so
any genes that do not undergo a fusion
are expected to have a similar ratio and
we analyze this and we plot it
statistically and give a confidence
value to show that this is a
indeed a normal non-fusion event
if there is a a break a translocation
and therefore a fusion transcript that's
created
then this expression ratio changes you
can see quite dramatically here
how there's a big big drop importantly
we also
map the position of these amplicons
according to the kinase domain because
of course you need an active kinase
domain
to make the driver um gene and the
fusion
uh pathogenic so the position of the
breakpoint is also very important
and this is this is revealed in the uh
the output of the instrument
so that was a little bit about the
oncoming precision assay
let's move on now to the myeloid assay
um which we'll be releasing later this
year
so in the past to detect this growing
number of important markers in myeloid
oncology
people would have to employ a series of
sequential tests be it sanger sequencing
pcr
qpcr or maybe even um outsourcing and
sending samples out
this of course becomes laborious it
becomes very time consuming and
inefficient
uh losing control of the sample if
you're sending it out and and can often
take many weeks
to get a result next generation
sequencing is
somewhat of a disruptive method about
methodology as we've
said before allowing you to do all of
this analysis in a single run
we have the oncoming myeloid assay which
we'll be releasing onto the genexis
platform later this year this has
40 dna targets and 29 fusion drivers
with
many many hundreds of different partners
and allows the test to be run within a
single day
from extraction of blood
or aspirate
bone marrow aspirate all the way through
sequencing
and out to the report can be completed
in a one-day turnaround time
and this is with the simultaneous
profiling of the dna mutations
and all of the rna fusion transcripts
into this integrated
report at the end we retain the
flexibility of sample throughput as well
and as i said we validate the validated
the approach
on whole blood lymphocytes and also bone
marrow
again it's the same limited um hands-on
time of 10 minutes for the whole process
with two touch points
all the way through to the annotated
variant report which lifts
clinical trials guidelines and labels
that are appropriate to the mutation
spectrum
that's um that's been determined by the
test
up to eight myeloid samples will be able
to be run
per day um all eight samples going into
a single lane of the gymnexus chip
so day one would be one lane day two
would be the next lane day three and so
on
the reagents on the deck of the platform
are stable for for many weeks
so you retain that flexibility it's
two-week guarantee
and you can come back day after day and
just reload however many samples that
you have
onto the platform
the purification system which is coming
which is launching a little later we'll
be able to process
up to 12 samples at one time with dna
and rna
this reveals then both an archive plate
of nucleic acid and a plate of dna and
rna that's ready to transfer directly
onto the genexis integrated sequencer
platform
this then runs the sequencing process
for four
samples over 17 hours and for
eight samples of dna and rna in just
over 21 hours
the content of the myeloid assay was
selected
um intentionally to cover a broad
spectrum of myeloid disorders so that's
aml
mds mpn cml
as well as cmml and jmml so
we've spent a lot of time and care
making sure we've selected the right
gene content these are broken up into
those genes we cover by hot spots with
those that we have
full exonic coverage of the gene you can
see the list here
these are the 29 fusion drivers as i've
said all with
with many many different partners with
their specific designs
we have some controls and also some
expression markers
whereby looking at recounts you can
determine over expression
of these relevant genes
all in all 40 dna genes
the 29 drivers have more than 600
different fusion
isotopes and we have the five expression
genes
and the controls
very easy to use very flexible and
robust
and a fully integrated end-to-end
solution from specimen all the way
through
to report
if you compare that to some alternative
approaches
we've tried to list here some key
factors that we feel are very important
to think about
one is the automated specimen to report
workflow where really you don't need any
high level of training you don't need to
spend more than a few minutes
in the entire process another is the
speed to result obviously it's
critical with myeloid disorders to have
information as quickly as possible and
the next day
ideally so having a one day turnaround
time is
is really significant significantly
important
next is the um the content um and the
detection of both
dna and rna targets with with one
stroke one straightforward assay
simultaneously
of course we feel it's important to have
the integrated analysis solution
all the way through in the software to
the report
and finally it's the coverage for all of
the key
myeloid and targets that you need for a
broad spectrum analysis
and the oncoming myeloid attack for
genexis ticks
all of these boxes
so to summarize we're very excited uh
with the launch
the of the myeloid assay on the genexis
sequencing system um it will simplify
and accelerate
myeloid profiling to a single day using
next generation sequencing
which will allow laboratories to get
rapid results for things like flip 3
itds cp53 cbp alpha
npm npm 1 kit
pml rara and all other biomarkers in a
single day
simultaneous simultaneously interrogate
all the relevant dna mutations and
fusion transcripts
for research on myeloid malignancies
covering
all the major myeloid disorders aml mds
mpn cml cmml and jmml
even challenging targets like uh the
flip three
um internal tandem duplications
are covered we have dedicated software
specifically for picking up
these these large and unusual events
and the report contains uh
all of the relevant guidelines and
labels and clinical trials
the oncoming myeloid assay is one of
a suite of um oncology assays
that we have on our older platforms that
we're progressively going to bring
through
to the genexis platform they all all
built on ambassador technology
um with a lot of care and attention on
software
the informatics for interpretation as
well as enhanced manufacturing quality
controls making sure that we're
producing
the highest grade material that goes
into all of these assays
with dedicated protocols to give some
clinical research samples
and we we validate the system and
process
using the the appropriate clinical
research samples
we also have dedicated teams to support
laboratories implementing implementing
these assays
so thank you very much for for your
attention i'll finish just with a
summary of this really
really exciting breakthrough in ngs
technology the genexis system it's the
world's
first turnkey automated ngs system
allowing a single day turnaround time
for instance you can get the full
myeloid results within a single day
automated sample purification library
preparation sequencing
and analysis it will vastly increase
reproducibility
and efficiency of any laboratory whilst
reducing personnel costs and training
time
it's really flexible with the multi-lane
system
in the chip you can run a few to a large
number of samples
reagents are stable on deck there's
there's negligible
wastage and we've manufactured these
um in the the highest quality systems
registered with the fda and iso 13 485
certified
so as you've heard we've um a growing
menu of oncoming assays we're porting on
to this exciting platform
and we're really excited with what the
future holds once again
thank you very much for your attention
and i believe there'll be the
opportunity for questions
coming up soon thank you
thank you so much john for that
wonderful presentation
and giving us an overview on the game
changing genexa system
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder to the audience please
submit your questions via the q a box
any questions that are not answered
today in the interest of time
will be addressed via email
all right john we've got several
questions coming in
uh my first question to you um
fusion think seems like a very powerful
tool what is the sensitivity or accuracy
for the detection of novel fusions such
as
enteract fusion using opa
well that's a that's a great question um
we
have had over 99
sensitivity and accuracy when testing uh
fusions in the samples that we've uh
we've got through our validation
exercises so it's extremely sensitive
thanks for that um there's another
question here
what's the maximum output in gigabytes
for
max reads per run of the new genexis
system
right yeah that will vary a little from
run to run but you should be
sort of 50 to 60 gigabytes on a complete
chip
of course the chip's divided into four
lanes and you can run each lane
separately but if you were to run the
complete chip i believe it's
it's 50 to 60 gigabytes
thank you for that another question we
have here
is what is the recommended minimum tumor
content percentage
in ffp samples for using the oncoming
precision assay
we've um we've tested it down to
um around 10 um
that's what we've used as our minimum
recommendation um
we're generally quite conservative with
the the metrics that we advise so
i suspect you'd have success going a
little lower but we test down to 10
tumor content
great um what is the qc required
for the dna and rna samples before
loading on to the genexis platform
and you don't need any any special um
treatment that's one of the the great
natures of the chemistry
and the instrument platform that we use
it's extremely robust
um so any standard um ffpe sample
um can be can be put onto the platform
there's no
particular specific special quality
controls needed
just whatever you have it's a sample you
can put on and expect success
okay um we have another question here on
um the consumables there's two weeks
consumable stability seems to be
short are there any plans to extend that
um right yeah so as you as you rightly
um
say the the symbols that you put onto
the deck of the platform
are stable there at the temperatures of
normal laboratory
for a period of time right now we're
guaranteeing at least two weeks
uh we do expect that to be extended
as we continue to test the platforms
that are out there and the
robustness of the chemistry on the on
the deck so yes two weeks for now but we
expect that to be extended
um can you elaborate a little bit more
about uh
the assays that are coming forth in 2021
on the platform
um yes absolutely um we
we intend to extend our portfolio
by bringing additional blood cancer
assays onto onto genexis in 2021
we also have ambitions of a larger
um fully very comprehensive hygiene
count over 500 gene
assay that we're expecting to bring in
2021
um and some other um developments um
some
mrd kind of applications that we're
quite excited by
but um yeah we've still somewhat to do
through this year to
see that come to fruition
okay thanks so much john um i think
that's been a great presentation
in the interest of time uh we will
probably end this session uh end this
presentation and move on to our next one
but to the audience is there any
questions that were unanswered we will
reach out to you
via email so i just like to thank uh
john again for his presentation
and to the audience for all your
questions thanks john
thank you thank you very much
next up we have dr michael hummel who is
the head of the molecular diagnostics
lab at the institute of pathology
in cherite berlin and a long-standing
researcher in molecular mechanisms in
malignant lymphoma
with more than 350 high-ranking
publications
for a complete biography on dr humel
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
today he will share with us his
experience with the new iron toronto
nexus system
as well as presenting evaluation data
from a multi-centric study
on the performance of the sequencer as
well as the new on combined precision
assay
please welcome please join me in
welcoming dr hummel
my name is michael arnold i'm head of
the molecular diagnostics at the
charity in a wonderful city of berlin
and i would like to guide you through
this presentation
dealing with next generation sequencing
and
new developments for this application
now the disclaimer
so sequencing is not a new
technology it already started 1977
when maximum gilbert reported
a new method for sequencing of dna
but nobody is using maxim gilbert
because there was a second
technology published in the same year
from senga and coulson
which was much more successful because
it was easier to handle in the lab
and to generate a sequencing so that is
also the reason
why the number of publication
applications using the maxim and gilbert
approach which is time consuming and
which is
lap consuming technology disappeared
almost completely
from the scenery and singer sequencing
was established initially it was a
radioactive
labeled system which was later on
replaced by
fluorescence labeled dyes and
we are all were all happy with this
technology
for many many years and it also
was uh the basis for the k-ras
testing and colorectal cancer a couple
of years ago
when there was an approval of the fda
for anti-egfr receptor antibodies for
colorectal cancer
because there's in many cases an over
expression on the protein level of these
molecules
but what was ignored at that time
that the over expression of the egf
receptor is not sufficient
what we need in addition is information
about the mutational status of the rus
molecule
if rus is mutated then this molecule is
able to initiate signaling
into the nuclei and to initiate cell
growth
so even with the anti-egfr antibodies
in the case of mutated kvs there was no
successful treatment and
it took some time uh until this
this testing was established in the
guidelines
for uh treating colorectal cancer
and as you can see here from our lab
it's a nice representation of senger
sequencing with the fluorescence dies
and the detection of carousel mutation
in this case
the patient will not benefit from the
treatment
continue
now a few years later now we are in the
year 2020
there was a lot of development over the
last years
and we have a number of already
established biomarkers
and much more are under evaluation
and even the term biomarker
received some addition so we initially
talked about the k
res mutation this is the green labeled
alteration
but in addition we have now
amplification
we have translocation we have
rna expression we have the protein
expression
we have some other alterations i come to
this a little bit later
and even non-human dna all these
categories can be regarded as
biomarkers and if we try to
translate this into the cancer types
and the most prominent one at the moment
is that long
a non-small lung cancer
you can see it's quite colorful we have
a number of
different alterations in in this disease
and also different categories ranging
from immunohistochemistry
to translocation generating fusion genes
and of course mutations but
lung cancer is not alone we have the gut
cancer
wouldn't we have many many other cancers
around
the body which carry different
types of alterations which
are quite to some extent
cancer specific but also
there's a some degree of overlap across
the different cancer types
but with sometimes different
functionality
and even breast cancer you can see the
only red
labeled category here the gene
expression there is
a gene expression which
is very typical for breast cancer
and helps the the understanding
of this disease more much better
so you see in this scheme
a broad variety of different alterations
and
different types of cancers which are
highly interesting
for the biology of these diseases
and it's now also time for pan cancer
alterations uh it's the anthrax
alteration it's the mutational burden
it's of course very classical the
morphology
and the microcellular satellite
instability
so these can be found in many of these
different cancer types
and if we just jump to the molecular
drivers in the non-small cell lung
cancer field you can see
there's a huge number of different
drivers in this disease and
the majority is still unknown and if you
have a very careful
look into the categories here you see
a very small frequency of this
driver mutations in this disease
and it's more to be detected in the
future
and if you translate this into histology
on the right hand
side you can also see that the non-small
cell lung cancer is not only
adenocarcinoma of the lung
but it's also squamous cell carcinoma
and some other type so it's broader than
usually uh thought in in the diet in the
discussions
and the frequency once again
and also in in the perspective of
different types of cancers we can
uh easily identify once again the
non-small cell lung cancer as the most
prominent category of cancers but
there is an emerging development at the
moment
that also other types of cancers are
becoming more and more interesting in
terms of
molecular alteration and molecular
subtyping
of these diseases
what do we need to cover those
broad molecular range of markers
then we are very quick in the field
of next generation sequencing because
singer sequencing
although this is a very nice technology
it's not capable enough
to detect multiple
different alterations in in one essay
and here for example the oncoming
precision essay
is a tool which covers most or almost
all of the relevant alterations
in different types of cancers 50 genes
have been compiled and this essay
covering almost 3 000 unique alterations
consisting of mutations copy number
variations and fusion events
and most logical
the non-small cell lung cancer is
very well represented here in the
oncoming
precision essay and here you can see
that this essay also respects
genes which are already labeled or in
guidelines
or even in in the use of clinical trials
so
you are able with this precision essay
to answer a lot of relevant questions
a very emotionally discussed
fields in oncology in the last years
at least two and three last two years
it's a detection of fusion events
causing
fusion transcripts which are nice
targets
for sequencing however
it's sometimes a bit tricky if you
if you have translocations and fusion
transcripts where you know
the driver gene but not fusion
partner that always raises some
technical
concerns how to to cover
this need to detect
a fusion event on the rna level
without knowing the fusion partner
and this was done in the oncoming
precision essay in different ways
so it's quite easy for the known fusions
where you know the driver
and the partner gene then you can
generate
a system for amplification
of this region which is highly sensitive
and very reliable this is also the case
if
the the sequence in between the driver
and the partner is not known
you can also identify quite easily
a system an amplification system which
is able
to sensitive to have a sensitive
amplification of this region
which is then very helpful for
sensitive detection it's more difficult
and more tricky
if the partner is unknown then you have
only the driver situation
and then you need to have some
bioinformatics
tools for the interpretation of the
sequencing data
these are rna-derived data in order to
identify to identify an imbalance
situation and
there was much um let's say advance
the last one or two years one or two
years
in order to optimize these type of
imbalance
excellent tiling system and the oncoming
precision essay is a very
well advanced system in this respect
but even the best gene panel for
mutation detection or amplification of
fusions
what we need in addition is a technology
able
to produce ngs data
in a high throughput throughput system a
very
rapid time frame and very reliable
the preparation of the libraries used
for
next generation sequencing is to some
extent
quite cumbersome and lab
intensive and of course there's a high
need
based on a growing number of samples
to do it very rapidly and
with the support of automated system
and here we have um
a nice new development which is the on
the iron toronto nexus system it's fully
automated
you can run it in one day
and without much
user intervention for this only
a few hands-on time needed
in order to run the entire system so you
start with the date dna or rna
and the rest will be done
by the machine including sample
purification
library prep of course the sequencing
and answer the
reporting of the data
so this system this genexa system
provides the user with a high degree of
flexibility
so we can run different essays in
parallel
we have multiplexing capability up to
32 libraries in a single run
we have a very nice feature which is the
the use of the reagents for up to
two weeks in the instrument which is
i think technician will like it um
we have um a
very nice colorful strip so avoiding
errors and mistakes
and placing the reagents into the
machine
and we have
a quite small footprint for such a
comprehensive machine in the lab so we
can really
be quite restricted with with the
storage space
we need and in addition which
will come very soon is a nucleic acid
purification and quantification system
so even that will be added to the
genexis system
to complete the entire workflow
in a very very elegant way
of course we are very interested not
only if we in berlin but
many sites across the globe
how this system is really working
because it sounds very
fantastic to have a system which
allows you to put in the dna and
then go away and let the machine work
so there was a decision
for a multi-center study for evaluation
of the genexis system
and the oncoming precision essay and
this was done
in portugal in porto in the switzerland
in basel
at the charity in berlin in germany and
in naples in italy
so we four centers joined forces in
order to
to test the genexis system in
combination
with the anchormine precision essay is
selected
from the each cluster customer site's
own samples which have been
recharacterized by other technologies or
assays
so we cannot really compare
across the sides the results but we have
of course the
the re-characterization of these samples
and we have done ffpe samples
we have analyzed liquid biopsies
um so the variant types the mutations
the copy numbers
and the fusions look quite broad
approach
for testing teach nexus system and the
oncoming
process precision essay
let's start with the mutation analysis
as you can see here
we have included a number of different
cancer types
altogether 45 samples
including some reference material which
you can see
under the term unknown
i think what is also very important in
the daily life
is the knowledge regarding the tumor
cellularity of each of the samples
because low tumor cellularity
might prevent detection of important
alterations
so that is always a challenge if it
comes to very low
tumor cellularity that is the overview
that was our starting point
and then first of all we checked for the
representation of well-known alterations
you see here
different types of hfr mutations pic3ca
mutation
character mutations and the two
mutations and you can see there's
a coverage at least in this set of
samples
which is quite convincing and
what is also a nice comparison is the
allelic frequency i mentioned
in the previous slides that we also
included
samples with a low
tumor cellularity and this is also
reflected here
you can see different alterations
which are covered by this essay and
a broad really broad range of allelic
frequencies
that is not only the tumor cell content
as usually
no we have in many many of these cancer
types also
to more heterogeneity which causes then
low allelic frequencies
and of course the most or one of the
most important
parts of the study is the comparison
with the
already existing data these have been
done with the focus essay or oncoming
focus essay
the solid tumor oncoming essay
amplisec colon and long version 2 panel
and from a different vendor the true
side 170
and on the right hand side you see a
very nice correlation of the
pre-existing
data with those generated with the oppa
and the genexa system and
this comparison is
summarized also in the at the small
table
you see a 100 percent specificity
and the concordance with is hundred
percent or
a little bit below hundred percent which
is very usual
if it comes to the comparison of
different technologies
next only a few numbers of cases
with copy number alterations because we
restricted our
comparison to already known observations
and you can see here
that this essay is also able
to detect copy number copy number
variations
which is usually quite easy if
you have a high copy number
amplification but it's more tricky
especially in combination with too much
low tumor content if there is a low copy
number amplification but this is
done very nicely here with the opa essay
you can see
the comparison here with these type of
amplifications
of very high interest is the detection
of fusion gene events
based on the rna level you can once
again see here that
the tumor samples used for for this
essay
so altogether 29 samples once again
the lung cancer is the most prominent
one
again important in additional
information
is the distribution of the tumor
cellularity and this goes down
to a range between 10 and 30 percent
um the detection of fusion variants is
represented here
you can see here a number of different
fusion events including the entrex
and the arc and some others
with the known fusion partners
in addition you can see the met exon 14
skipping event auto detect detected
on the rna level
once again the summary of these fusion
events you can see we
included cases where which were
re characterized by a variety of
different essays
including the rjdxsa
the two side 170 and
of course the very traditional methods
the fish
essay and again the specificity is
extremely high 100 percent
but also the concordance to already
existing
data is uh of really
really impressive high value
for the unknown fusion partners
i already mentioned at the beginning of
this presentation there was the
development of
the new bioinformatics algorithm in
order to
identify those unbalanced situation on
the rna
here you can see some very nice examples
how the detection of fusion genes works
in the upper level
you can see the targeted isoform
detection
and this was done for three different
samples
and you should realize
that especially the n-track one and the
red
examples have a very low tumor content
so you can see only a limited number of
reads whereas the antrex iii fusion
was very in a tumor sample with a very
high tumor load
so that is the usual way it goes
but in the lower level you can also see
the imbalance
detection which is nicely demonstrating
that there is sufficient information
available
to identify not only the imbalance
but also the location of the break
in the gene identifying
the remaining kinase functionality which
is important
for as a as a target for further
analysis but this approach allows you
also
in the case of unknown fusion partners
to do a reliable detection
of the fusion gene situation
and finally also becoming more and more
important are the liquid biopsies you
can see
here from the numbers that we included
12
samples most of them have been
derived from non-small cell lung cancer
samples
interestingly in also our experience it
is not
always possible to
extract the recommended 20 nanograms of
circulating
tumor dna in this case in our
case collection of 12 samples in some
cases we were
very low in the in the number in the
concentration and the amount of
circulating tumor dna but let's see what
comes out
you can see here that the distribution
of the
of these alterations in the in
the plasma samples and liquid biopsies
most of them
not unexpected egfr
mutations including the t1790m mutation
of course you will find covers and p53
mutation
and some others and as you can see
even in those cases with the very low
amount of circulating tumor dna
the detection was really successful
and finally you can see here again the
concordance
with the pre-existing data specifically
100 percent for all the alterations
and almost 100 percent congruency
for also for all the alterations
and this is also illustrated in the
graph on the on the right hand side
where you see a very high correlation
correlation with the pre-existing data
so if we come to a overall
summary and conclusion of of the data
you can see here that
the system the genexis in
combination with the oncoming precision
essay
is a very specific system and also
compared with a variety of different
technology we were able with a high
concordance and a high sensitivity
different types of alterations
in formally fixed tissue samples but
also
in liquid biopsies in the circulating
dna
present in the plasma so that is a very
impressive result and this was
not from one single site these are the
data from
four different sites across europe
i think this highlights uh to
a very high degree the reliability of
that
approach let me conclude at the end
um i think
this increase of alterations
is really demanding and it's becoming
progressively dis
demanding in the future so we have the
challenge
to cover this demands of the
of the entire system
we need to be flexible in order to
cover the diagnostic needs
we need to minimize the workload because
technicians and scientists are
quite expensive and we have to save
their
working hours to do the data
interpretation and not
only the lab work so automation is very
welcome and i think that the genexis has
a
really great potential for as a future
solution
to combine all steps of diagnostic next
generation
sequencing and what we have seen in this
study across different sites the data
are very robust
and reliable which provides an excellent
basis
also for the introduction in many more
labs finally i want to acknowledge
the very excellent cooperation with the
colleagues at
the different sites also very nice
communication in cooperation with the
colleagues from thermo fisher scientific
and of course
from my team to the sport cart and
carsten
who really supported this work
to a very very broad extent and thank
you very much
for your attention
thank you so much dr hamel for that
fantastic talk
um we do have a few questions coming
into the live q a portion of this
presentation
let me start with the first question how
do you address
the recovery of good reads from ffpe
samples
considering that these samples pass
through
dehydration steps that might have
significant effect to the dna
well that is a good question but not a
new question
because sequencing and next generation
sequencing
which is applicable to dna
and rna derived from formally in fixed
material
is already in use for a couple of years
what we see if the tissue
material is fixed
under well-defined and good conditions
then we do not have a real problem
using those kind of extracted dna and
rna
for very very good sequencing
overfixation
for a long time or fixation in
unbuffered formalin or fixation
at high temperatures is a very bad
idea causing dna
and rna elements which are not
really good for sequencing irrespective
of next generation sequencing or
singular sequencing
so i do not see a real problem using dna
and rna extracted from good
prepared in fixed material
thank you for that we have another
question would you recommend
the cell free dna samples as an
alternative to tissue biopsy samples
to avoid issues or concerns on tumor
heterogeneity
good once again a very good question so
the liquid biopsies are always thought
to represent the kind of average of the
tumor heterogeneity
however that is not completely sure
so what we see usually is a very low
amount of cdna copies
cfdna copies in in the plasma
and it's not clear whether this is a
full representation
of the tumor heterogeneity in addition
in some of the tumors
where we know from imaging that tumor is
in the body there is no circulating
tumor dna detectable
so it's quite unclear so far whether
this
kind of average approach in the liquids
biopsies
is really reliable so the idea is is
good
but i think we do not have enough
knowledge currently
to answer this question with the
required reliability
okay i can if you want um so
alternative to tissue biopsies i think
this is an
addition not a replacement of the tissue
bio
uh bio specimens so um yes i like it
very much but
as a kind of addition and not as a
replacement
yes absolutely um there's another
question here
uh what is your take on panel-based ngs
approach
versus single gene testing such as ihc
of fish
[Music]
let's compare the monastery chemistry
with
sequencing with dna based sequencing
we are talking about different types of
molecules so
once for the immunohistochemistry it's
protein based
using antibodies for the detection
sequencing in many cases is dna based so
we have
a different level of molecules
the fish approach again is dna based
and we do not see in the fish the
consequence on the rna and
protein level so we should always keep
in mind that we are talking about
different
types of molecules with different
function
for practical reasons dna is quite good
to handle it's a very
good type of molecule for
fish for dna sequencing
and so it's often used in the lab
immunizer chemistry on another side is
antibody dependent so you need very good
antibodies
to do a proper detection of your
molecule of choice if you use
for example the be rough antibody yes
you can identify certain type of
be rough mutation but
the the sensible sensitivity
and the reliability is not hundred
percent
um you have much it's a much better
approach to use the dna because you have
more
information fish for the trans locations
yes
that is very time consuming it's a very
nice
technology but once again you do not see
the consequence on the rna and protein
level you see
only the chromosomal breaks which might
be sufficient
in in a huge number of
questions but not always if you what is
it current strength if you
need to detect multiple different
translocations because if you do not
because you do not know at the beginning
of your investigation
what might be the targeted
fusion then of course next generation
sequencing based on
rna is a very very good idea
because you can identify
a huge number of potential fusion genes
in one essay regarding single
or multi multiple gene detection i'm
having much in favor for the multichain
detection because what we can see
in addition not only the egfr or the
companion diagnostics approved molecules
we can also identify additional
alterations
qualifying the patients for clinical
trials
and i think this is a really really
major added value
because that drives development
to a very large extent
thank you so much for that insight dr
humble and thank you once again for
coming on board and presenting at our
genetic solutions tour
uh in the interest of time um i think we
will end
this session here but we will now take a
15 minute
break before the start of the next
session so grab a coffee walk around the
event
and check out the various application
tracks that may be of interest to you
the clinical oncology session will
continue after the break
but during this break please visit our
booth and learn about some very exciting
promotions that are available to the
audience
and interact with our thermo fisher
representatives at our booth
who are right there to answer any of
your questions
please do not forget to check the
leaderboard on the top right side of the
screen
to see what activities are available
including a scavenger hunt
look out for our special icons in the
environment to win prizes
there will be a pop-up survey appearing
in a minute so please do help us by
completing this survey
thank you again and see you back in the
auditorium in 15 minutes to continue
our clinical oncology session
okay bye-bye
thank you dr ammo
you